the mind is mighty favorite Texas Paul
is joining us Texas Paul how are you
this morning
oh man I'm I am sad brother I am sad I
have been what's going on over there
you know it's looking more and more like
South Texas hey you know when you you
know it Texas is different we're just
different people here we we have this
sense of pride in our state that's just
like no other I mean it is like no
weather I mean I get I get family
members that come down here and they're
like what the hell is with all the flags
man and I'm like that's just Texas man
we're just bad they're like what are you
proud of and be in Texas you know
and everything I looked at today for
today's preparation just
South Texas is turning into South Africa
apartheid South Africa it's just
the the last few weeks of stories I've
done have just broken my heart I mean
they're just
I tell you Tony you and I got to clean
up our own backyard
we really do I mean I don't know what is
wrong
with the white guys these days but uh
yeah we got we gotta we've got to clean
up so I learned something new today I
never wanted to learn in my life you
know what uh
immigration calls
uh
Asylum Seekers migrants hmm
Tonks
do what
Tonks have you ever heard have you heard
this Gabe Sanchez have you heard this
before
Tonks
Tonks t-o-n-c Tonk you know what that is
no no that's a sound that's the sound a
human head makes when you hit it with
one of these flashlights oh Jesus Christ
that is what Customs and Border Patrol
agents after they graduate from the
the academy in Glenn County Georgia
and head down to South Texas the senior
agents teach them to refer to migrants
as Tonks
um and it's just that whole culture
that's leading to what we're talking
about today you know we just had a
warden of the West Texas Detention
Center down in Sierra Blanca you know
have you ever heard of Fort Stockton
Texas you know Billy the Kid that whole
story I I know I know the Billy the Kid
story but the the name Fort Stockton
Escapes Me he would he would often cross
into Mexico through Fort Stockton he
would because you know most of his his
activities were in New Mexico and he
would cut through to Texas just get you
know to cross into Mexico
um you know through the Chihuahuan
Desert and Fort Stockton was just uh
friendly to him so he used it a lot well
Sierra Blanca is a little town just
outside Fort Stockton
and that's where the West Texas
Detention Center is the used to be an
ice facility and they now this is
privately owned this is a privately
owned facility yeah owned by a company
called LaSalle okay uh they had a
contract with ice and Ice revoked that
contract late in 2019.
um but this guy remained on as the
warden of that facility
and he is the guy that was driving down
the highway
uh last week and saw a group of
immigrants
uh jumped out of his pickup truck and
there were 13 of them 11 of them went
and hid behind a water tower and two of
them hid behind a bush right and
according to testimony from all the
witnesses he told the immigrants in
Spanish he said come out here you little
[ __ ] come on you little asses
in Spanish He yells at him and they
didn't come out uh so he popped Two
Shots into the bushes they were hiding
he hit man in the head and killed him
and shot a woman in the stomach Jesus
Christ now this is this is the one
because he's with his twin brother right
is that right we saw we saw their their
pictures on social media and it kind of
got buried underneath other stories
right right the hurricane they got
married underneath the hurricane so uh
Mike Shepard is the is the warden of the
West Texas Detention Center at the time
um and his brother Mark you know yells
at him did you get him and uh they hop
back in their pickup truck and they just
leave them there's a squirrel or
something Jesus Christ they just leave
them for dead didn't they tried to say
because when the investigation happened
when everybody else carried the woman
you know the woman survived she's in an
El Paso hospital
um
you know everybody gave testimony they
went back and looked at camera footage
to see what truck fit the description
they were able to pick the brothers up
they said oh we were out hunting grouse
and uh we we were shooting at grass
and I said really uh can we see your
shotgun okay why does it have Buckshot
in it if you're hunting breasts oh did I
say Grouse I meant we were hunting I
have a leaning we saw javelina Hogs is
what we saw
so the prosecutor
um
and I'll give him credit for this he
didn't charge him with murder he didn't
charge him with murder he charged them
uh with manslaughter
and the reason for that why do you give
them yeah why do you give them credit is
that is that because you think that this
is going to stick to them more than the
murder charges
yeah this is there's no way to lose this
right no matter what if you fire into a
bush
and you shoot a human being you're
guilty of manslaughter
because you shot a deadly weapon
at a Target that you couldn't identify
knowing that there's human beings in
that bush yeah well he he's claiming he
didn't know that but it's Irrelevant in
the manslaughter charge because you
didn't identify your Target and you
fired anyways
it doesn't matter what you thought you
saw in in a manslaughter okay that's why
I'm giving that that attorney props he's
going to take a lot of heat a lot of
people are going to want murder charges
and he's going to take a lot of heat for
it but he is a smart prosecutor he is
he's going to get them on manslaughter
and hopefully the judge will will you
know maximize a sentence which will
which would be a normal murder
conviction anyways
um you mean you mean in Texas if the if
the judge wants to sentence him to the
maximum amount it would be almost the
same as what a murder charge
um
right right like if they got him for
murder two you know they're not going to
usually give a maximum sentence out
although there is depraved indifference
in this one I mean it's it's it's a
horrible horrific story
but it gets worse guys I mean it gets
worse I mean
um this guy back in 2018 they had a
report on his prison and they had some
somalis that were held there
and uh they pepper sprayed these somalis
so bad that they were coughing up blood
they'd beat them
horribly uh sexually assaulted them
made a habit of grabbing them by the
pardon the expression but grabbing them
by the dick and pulling them around
um
the warden himself took part in this the
the uh the same guy that shot into the
bush right yeah the warden himself took
part in this he he uh you know would
often oversee these abuses uh and
imagine being in in solitary confinement
how small that cell is and just getting
soaked with pepper spray so bad that you
can't stop coughing until you're
coughing up blood
you know and one of these guys I was
reading the actual report it's a long
report but it was worth the read one of
these guys the reason he was there was I
mean he was married to an American
they'd been living here forever he
thought he was naturalized to be quite
honest he may still have a case but he
doesn't want doesn't want to come back
um
his parents were naturalized he can't
remember if he was 17 or 18 if he was 17
when his parents naturalized he was
naturalized he became a citizen if he
was 18 then he's got to go through the
naturalization process himself
but he's not even going to fight that
because he does not want to come back to
America he does not this guy the warden
punched because he asked for underwear
and socks because they were not giving
them clothes to change into I mean they
were just the same clothes forever
they were washing them in the toilet and
[ __ ] like that trying to yeah he said
can I get a pair of underwear and socks
the warden
punched him in the face four times
and uh
the the guy said because there was a
medical staff there attending somebody
said she said you're going to let him do
this don't you see this the guy the
medical officer turned around and says I
didn't see anything
I didn't see anything
so when he's in in confinement the
warden came for a visit and while he was
handcuffed to the ground just started
kicking the [ __ ] out of him in his ribs
till he was coughing up blood
and that's that's that's this Prince
that murdered these migrants
the worst part is he stayed in his job
this report went to a federal prosecutor
in West Texas the federal prosecutor
took a look at it and said okay some of
this was done in front of ice agents
uh we we we need to run this up the
ladder and it ran up to the AG and doj
and died
who was the AG at the time
Jeff sessions hmm
one Jeff sessions the one that went down
to the border and denigrated people
coming here and seeking Refuge I seem to
remember that yeah yep that's where all
the abuses and everything started the
separating the kids and all that stuff
and you know ice was out of control
think about this guy
the reason his story is important was he
was busted in 2013 for having a little
grass I don't mean distribution win I
mean he had some grass
right
so they said we're going to deport you
well they couldn't if you remember at
the time in Somalia there was a war
going on right that went on for like a
decade but so they said well we can't
Deport you you just report to ice every
year and and live your life go on we'll
worry about you later of course when
Trump came into office he's like send
them all out get rid of all of them so
he goes to check in and and
they arrest him right there in front of
his family
send them to the West Texas Detention
Center where all this happened
so anyways they deported him he
converted to Christianity
and that's a No-No in Somalia
um I don't remember know if you remember
Black Hawk Down and all the Warlords and
all everything that was going on in
Somalia and Mogadishu all of that that I
mean
um they deported every one of these
somalis back to the middle of that war
zone
several of them were here seeking Asylum
because they had spoken out
against
these abuses in Somalia we use them for
their their their
stories and then we deported them under
Trump
I mean it's just it's got me so down
guys I just this is not my Texas this is
not my people you know and I just
I just man I'm I I'm I'm enraging inside
I'm just raging inside because
you know I grew up in South Texas I did
and this is not
you know man growing up in South Texas
is like growing up in L.A you know I
mean it's just we're all
these divides aren't there until you get
these [ __ ] wackadoodles
and I'm telling you Tony that's why
we've got to clean up our backyard man
we really do I don't know what the [ __ ]
is wrong with with white people these
days man and I'm just gonna say it man
white guys [ __ ] suck right now
um
you know I had a conversation just
last Sunday with the with the guy blew
his mind His Name Was Daryl he's like
you should we were having a discussion
on what to do going forward and then I
was telling well we need more engagement
we need to be together you know because
I know I grew up in an environment where
there was no you know difference it
didn't matter what color you were we
were all together you know because we we
were at each other's homes and and you
know I mean hell [ __ ]
you know they called me Gordo forever
you know what I mean that was my
nickname for the longest time you know
look at look at caveman he knows what
Gordo means
pinche Flacco but
[Laughter]
but you grow up together and you don't
have that Hate in Your Heart man and he
said yeah but all white people are
racist
he said admit it and I said well yeah
we all are
we grow up segregated for the first part
of our lives and we grew up racist
because there's the other that's that's
human nature it's programmed into us we
we look at somebody who's different
and we immediately this is our tribe and
that's your tribe we're fight or flight
program for it and to claim that we're
not is a lie it's a lie and
the cure for that is to
spend time together
so that when I look at somebody I'm not
seeing the other
that's just my brother
you know that's how I become My
Brother's Keeper you know I mean I say
it all the time and my we are the am I
My Brother's Keeper party because we
spend time with each other we we love
each other man we're human beings you
know I want us good for for everybody as
I do for myself but these [ __ ]
Republican rightening [ __ ] man
you know people like Jeff sessions who
grew up in [ __ ] Alabama was
segregated himself his whole goddamn
life this that and the other creates a
policy in my [ __ ] state
that creates this culture with ice and
Border Patrol and everybody and you know
I I don't blame
all border patrol agents because they go
in when these but border patrol agents
go in
man it's like I was I was reading a
report from Human Rights Watch that was
talking about how broken our border
patrol is
you know these guys are working with
[ __ ] militias man racist militias
down here
and border patrol agents are like buddy
buddy with them
these new Agents come in and they're
good people they're they're they want to
do the right thing but you put them into
this broken [ __ ] culture
and within five or six years you've got
another [ __ ] broken agent you do yeah
I mean
I don't know what to tell you man I mean
other than kicking ass and taking names
I don't know what to do about this
problem man I really don't I mean
to fix it we all have to cut this [ __ ]
out but to cut the [ __ ] out we're going
to have to put our boots on the [ __ ]
necks of these [ __ ] Republicans with
this goddamn culture this division
[ __ ] they're always trying to sew I
mean every goddamn election look what
Abbott's doing down here it's an
invasion it's an invade [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what you know why
they're saying that you want to really
know why they're saying that give it to
me guns
guns it all boils down to [ __ ] guns
again because we sell a [ __ ] ton of guns
going the other way across the goddamn
border so they want you to focus
remember they're always saying accuse
your enemy
they get it from Joseph [ __ ] gerbils
the Nazi accuse your enemy of what
you're guilty of so they accuse them of
smuggling they accused them of being
dangerous they accused them of being
violent well we're the [ __ ] dangerous
and violent ones we're exporting our
[ __ ] guns every major Clash that the
Mexican government has had with cartels
down there they pick up off the dead
American [ __ ] guns
American [ __ ] guns these guns aren't
made in Mexico man
they're not shipped in through Mexico
they're shipped in through the Texas
[ __ ] border
and that's the problem
yeah sure there are drugs coming north
but 85 percent of the [ __ ] fentanyl
they're claimed they're bitching about
is brought in by Americans
Cato Institute I don't agree with a
[ __ ] conclusion that the Cato
incident comes up with because they're
libertarian they're libertarian and I've
never agreed with Libertarians
but their facts are never wrong
they don't lie
now what they
deduce from those facts I disagree with
but they don't lie about their facts
right because what you're saying is
they're like oh there's this many pounds
of fentanyl coming across the border so
that's why this group is failing like
well that's not you're you're twisting
the fact you're using the fact well I
mean when you when when you see tweets
of of people uh that literally say this
was seized you're you have to stop and
say do you know what the word means do
you know like just by by you Tweeting
that They seized this many pounds
hundreds of pounds of whatever the drug
is you then have to stop and say do you
understand what the actual definition of
seas means like you're not you're not
completely grat like getting what you're
what you're tweeting out right now which
is they're doing their job and you're
criticizing them for doing their job but
saying that they're not doing their job
so but you see it all the time I mean
you you know you you just mentioned like
the projection you know you like Joseph
groble's like you wanna you wanna blame
others for the very thing you're guilty
of and whether it's an abortion whether
it's trafficking humans whether it's uh
deaths by gun whatever it might be
these are all things that the Republican
party is guilty of and will project onto
anyone else to justify
the act that they can then do which is
to buy more guns or to enforce more
policies or restrict restrict more
rights or whatever it might be
it's then obviously to control like we
know that it works
and we've seen it before
and we've talked about on the show like
fascism you know isn't new and it's not
inventive and it's it it regurgitates
the same types of things that they do
again and again so that's why it's like
oh we know exactly what it is in a
Playbook they're trying to do because
we've literally seen it before on
multiple occasions
um they they don't reinvent the wheel
here they're still the same fascist
regime that wants to strip away rights
that you know you should be you should
be given or you're or that you're born
with right
um
and that's Republican party it is
completely full of projection you it you
cannot and that talking point there
doesn't ever get old because every
single day there's a new story there's a
new accusation whatever it might be is
proving that that party is guilty of the
very thing that they're they're accusing
others of being
absolutely absolutely there the
Republican party today is useless it's
useless it's rotten to the core you know
Rhonda you were talking about Ron
DeSantis earlier Tony I just did a a an
entire show last night on Ron DeSantis
he
you know ship those Folks up to Martha's
Vineyard spent 12 million dollars
everybody says how many how much water
would 12 million dollars have bought but
then again
he made the hypocrisy meter explode
because his people are now up in New
York
recruiting those same Venezuelan
migrants
to come work in Florida to clean up This
Disaster Area they're offering them
fifteen dollars an hour to work in the
most contaminated
[ __ ] up environment you've ever seen
there's dead people dead dogs feces
chemicals this is a horrendous shop it's
Hazard pay is what they should be
getting and then they're offering them
fifteen dollars a day per diem for food
yeah so you're not going to see any
buses going from Abbott or DeSantis for
a while because they're going to use
them in Florida
and it the [ __ ] hypocrisy of it man
these people are [ __ ] stains on Humanity
they just
make me sick and then of course you know
you've already you've already talked
about the story I'm sure about uh
they've privatized their disaster
release fund Relief Fund and it's a
[ __ ] 501c3 charity run by desantis's
wife they're gonna steal money is what
they're gonna do
yeah she's like she's a she's a goddamn
team local TV anchor
he's a local TV anchor you know Michelle
Obama was an executive in a Health Care
system
you know this woman knew how to manage
money assets resources and people
Cassidy DeSantis is a [ __ ]
local television station news anchor
what the [ __ ] does she know about
disaster relief what needs to be done
well she knows how to steal money she's
going to get advice from old DeSantis I
mean that's the fact of the matter here
is that and I think is what you're
trying to drive at with this whole
conversation is that the Republican
party again like you said is rotten to
the core but it is like a [ __ ] sandwich
eating a [ __ ] sandwich and it is not
hard like I said as when the hurricane
was on its way to Florida I said Ron
DeSantis is totally gonna [ __ ] this up
and I don't need to know anything more
than it's Rhonda Santos who is the
governor that's all I need to know I
don't need to know anything past that
point just like in Georgia we watch this
drama play out on Twitter last night and
this morning of Herschel Walker and his
son well you didn't need to know
anything more anything more that it was
Herschel Walker and Donald Trump
endorsed him to know that this was gonna
go south just like the Dr Oz and you
know Dr Oz is probably be happy this
morning because him [ __ ] torturing
animals is now out of the news and
Christian Walker and his dad fighting is
in the news
I don't you know what I'm not paying a
[ __ ] bit of attention to that
warnock's gonna kick the [ __ ] out of him
I don't give a [ __ ] about I didn't give
a [ __ ] about Herschel Walker I do care
about all of these Floridians you're
talking about these the United States
home of boats okay I've got a bay boat
guys I do I've got a nice bait boat I
can run in a foot of water one foot 12
inches of water and I can drive my boat
through it I mean it they are all over
Florida I love the saltwater fish they
are all over Florida Sanibel Island all
the burial islands out there
they've got people out there desperate
for water and food today why we're
having this conversation right in the
home of [ __ ] boats
you're telling me nobody has put
together
a warehouse a distribution system I
don't know told people hey bring your
[ __ ] boats and bring your ass here
like we did in Houston you remember in
Houston when we had Harvey boats running
up and down the street picking people up
you know they were reporting to local
officials that were telling them
coordinating with them telling them
check this road okay we've checked that
road check it off you know I mean yeah
they were going house to house to house
to try to get people out
Republicans cannot [ __ ] do this
because they're not there to govern I
[ __ ] you not Rhonda Santos is at a
[ __ ] Waffle House
a [ __ ] Waffle House doing a photo op
and we still have people stranded we
still have if I was a governor
I could not sleep until I knew
everything was running like a well-oiled
machine and people were being rescued
and I mean I might you couldn't keep my
ass out of a boat
that's because though that's because you
actually have the low bar of decency
that's the problem here is we can't even
we can't even get the Republican party
and its leaders to reach the low bar of
just plain human decency and that's why
I knew he was gonna fail there was no
way Ron DeSantis was going to be able to
to make to make it happen to where all
Floridians and this and this was done in
the most proper way he failed the moment
the storm hit Fort Myers because he
didn't warn those people the governor
has the ability to send out a warning
and he did not he did not send out a
warning for those people to evacuate
and if you've seen the video you know
that it should have been given
hours in advance to get as many people
out of those places as possible and like
you said he shows up in Saint Augustine
with out in a pair of white boots
flipping waffles where there's a few
down branches and you know the thing is
people in Florida understand that [ __ ]
because what Rhonda santis is doing and
here's what he's doing Texas Paul
he's playing a national game here he's
not playing the game for Florida he's
not he's playing the game to run for
president in 2024 and he knows that he
can't piss off his his Tail Waggers all
around the country
he can't piss that he can piss
Floridians off you know what's the big
deal he can't piss off the Tail Waggers
all around the country the the
moguladites the America First Nazi party
and he was playing right that's what's
the problem with the entire Republican
party is the culture they that's why you
can have every Republican in Florida
vote against or Marco Rubio would not
even show up for the vote because
Democrats
you know guys do you know why they did
that you know why they voted against
that money
I didn't want to give Democrats a win as
if it was a win for Democrats not a win
for Floridians what do you think there
is you know political strategy there's
always political strategy you win some
you lose some the Democrats got them
there was gonna they wanted to shut down
they wanted to make a big thing they had
a big media push ready for defunding the
Biden Administration the criminal Biden
Administration they're criminals look
you know remember Mark Howe the guy
they're Prosecuting they're saying oh
this poor he loves babies and they're
just Prosecuting him because he's
anti-abortion and he really beat up a 72
year old guy twice you know what I mean
it's like [ __ ] like that just they they
this big push that the bidens were
criminals they wanted to defund the
government
the debt ceiling vote was coming up so
the Democrats have foxed and they said
fine we had a hurricane we need to fund
FEMA all the FEMA funding is in the debt
ceiling Bill vote
instead of taking the L and saying okay
that didn't work
they did it anyways
they've literally tried to shut down the
government that's what those no votes
were for they wanted to shut down the
government in the middle I mean three
days in two days into this
[ __ ] relief the worst disaster or you
know Florida state is called Rhonda
Santos called it a 500 year storm by the
way yeah he called about a 500 year
storm
and every Republican still played this
[ __ ] game
the game like you said was worth more to
them
than helping the people that they're
supposed to be helping right I mean
you're looking for constituents you know
we we've shown the clips before is like
you show you show Ron DeSantis on Tucker
Carlson and he plays the game of like I
had to request I had to request the
money from Joe Biden as opposed to Joe
Biden already being like hey money
resources whatever you need we've got
you because you are Americans you are
part of the United States there's no
reason why I would cut you off from any
sort of funding or help when there's
people's lives and and well-being at
risk and then you've also got that uh
Stu Studio guy or whatever the [ __ ] his
name is he's he's on there being like I
wrote a letter to Joe Biden and he had
to sign that letter for us to get and
it's like but just a few days prior
Joe Biden had already said hey look this
is what we're doing we're giving the
money like I'm already I'm already
calling this a disaster this is
something that's already going to get
our attention I'm at FEMA I'm having
conversations I'm dealing with Logistics
I'm actually running this country like a
president and not picking and choosing
who gets help and who doesn't get help
and the Republican Party
is going to vote against their
constituents right they're going to take
the money as they want it because
they're going to grift you know Ron
DeSantis wife that party will take away
from others that they're supposed to be
representing and then they'll blame it
on some and again it's the projection
they'll blame it on others and be like
whoa look dude I I I I told them I wrote
them a very strongly worded email and a
tweet and the truth social post or
whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ] that they
write and said I I told Joe Biden I told
Joe Biden that he had to do what I said
and he had to help my people meanwhile
Joe Biden is doing it
and they're they're voting against it
but their narrative has to be we vote
well we voted against it because there
was pork in there there was something
else in there God forbid we help some
other region that was affected by
Hurricane Ian or what have you but
because it wasn't directly all the money
to this person or to this group in
Florida then we have to say oh no no no
no no no we had to vote against it it
was for your well-being you wouldn't you
know just just calm yourself down I know
what's best for you because I'm the
governor or I'm the representative or
I'm the senator I mean all of these
[ __ ] idiots are incompetent and they
should not be running a state let alone
a state that every year goes through
this same [ __ ] thing the same type of
natural disaster and doesn't prepare
them you have 365 days sometimes less
than that but you know due to Science
and Technology we can track this we know
the pattern in which it goes we can say
hey we predict this is the pattern it's
going to go through so we we want to
make sure that we have people on the
ready to repair lines we've got people
on the ready to disperse resources but
instead they sit with their hands like
sit on their hands and say
okay well
this storm came out of nowhere guys we
couldn't have predicted it it's it's
it's frustrating it's frustrating it's
what it is well but it's the same thing
that you were talking about earlier
Texas Paul at this at the Border in
Texas where it's this it's the same
[ __ ] the same [ __ ] where they
use they use what is reality and they
use it to spend it in their little
stupid way and they and they don't
actually do the thing that is like
policy and governing treating people
like human beings and and just doing the
thing that you need to do which is uh
govern
they don't do that and they're not and
again that's why it's so easy to predict
how much they're going to fail because
they suck at this they totally suck at
this and really honestly it's
intentional they're they're they're
they're sucking of government is
completely intentional it's to tear down
your democracy tear down your ability to
want to even participate and once you
stop participating they have full
control to do whatever the hell they
want steal whatever the hell they want
treat people however the hell they want
and that is why we have to lean into
democracy that's why we have to pay
attention that's why I love having you
here on Tuesdays because I think I think
this situation in Florida with this
storm and the situation at the border
can be boiled down to you know what
you're not going to stop people from
coming across the border to seek Asylum
they want to come here it's a legal
process and you're not going to stop
people from illegally crossing to come
here for work because the [ __ ] [ __ ]
process to come here legally for work is
so stupid it's ridiculous because no
[ __ ] Republican will sit in a room
and make sure that that process is done
in a simple form so people can come here
and contribute to our economy legally
when it's just much easier to just cross
illegally and work it's the same
situation you know A hurricane's going
to hit Florida you know what it you know
that the damage could be great and you
sit on your [ __ ] hands and do nothing
even after it's done and over with it's
the same [ __ ] Republican way the same
thing whether you're in Florida right
now with the disaster are are you
talking about the southern Border in
Texas same [ __ ]
you know little man what you were
talking about it being intentional this
is what's going to happen in Florida
this is intentional they are funneling
all of their their efforts through you
know you've got the Florida defense fund
well there's there's another half to
that it's volunteer Florida is the other
half of it that's where they do the
actual cleanup and [ __ ] like that is
through volunteer Florida which is tied
to the Florida defense fund this [ __ ]
charity
they're setting it up to intentionally
[ __ ] fail in Florida and then they
were going to going to turn around and
try to blame Biden because they know for
a fact FEMA will not work with the
Florida defense fund they don't work
that way FEMA does not work through
layers of an onion
FEMA goes to the Red Cross
and says what do you need FEMA goes to
the Salvation Army and says what do you
need FEMA does not go to the Florida
defense fund and say Here's my checkbook
go pay these people because they don't
need to pay salaries in between here and
there they have people on the ground
there
to help Catholic Charities distribute
clothes that's what FEMA does and how
FEMA Works they've got a volunteer army
it's called crew it's it's a the it's a
reserve uh it's a job you can get with
with FEMA it you don't work until
there's a disaster and then they call
you up and you go and they pay you very
well to go do clean up or managers to go
out and meet with ngos and and stuff
like that they'll work with local
you know cities and state workers
absolutely
if State Workers are like man we don't
have enough equipment feed them is like
equipment
we'll rent it we got it we got you no
problem whatever you need we're there
but they will not [ __ ] cut checks to
organizations like
uh the floor the Florida disaster fund
they will not put that layer in between
what they're doing and DeSantis knows
this that's why he's intentionally one
telling everybody this is where you
donate
this is where you donate don't send
money or food or I mean don't send food
or or water or anything like that send
money directly to this fund but he knows
FEMA's already there but Freeman's not
working with these people
they're not they're not going to work
with these people they they that's not
how they operate that's why when you saw
in Puerto Rico
FEMA had a [ __ ] ton of water sitting on
the docks
they had made arrangements with ngos to
distribute it
and the [ __ ] uh
sorry ass I can't remember his name uh
the president of Puerto Rico that
corrupt [ __ ] wanted to put his
company in there to distribute that
water
and FEMA's like it's delivered we made
arrangements that's what we do
you want to [ __ ] your people that's on
you and that's the same thing that's
going to happen
unless it gets to be Katrina bat if it
gets to be Katrina level bad the federal
government will federal law is this
response which to me looking at this
whole cluster [ __ ] DeSantis has set up
needs to happen immediately we we need
to learn from Katrina and say you cannot
do this right you cannot [ __ ] do this
you just made a TV anchor in charge of
your disaster relief you are [ __ ]
incompetent and they need to federalize
the National Guard down there and FEMA
needs to take over now instead of
waiting until people are dying from
[ __ ] dysentery out on Sanibel Island
you know I mean it's just
you see it Tony you see it Gabe I see it
anybody that's watching what's going on
down in Florida Jesus Christ they're
pulling dead kids out of the Lee County
Juvenile Facility because the [ __ ]
Republican Sheriff down there would not
Evacuate the juvenile facility [ __ ]
crazy
they're pulling dead kids out of this
jail right now
but DeSantis is going to lie about it
DeSantis is going to lie he lied about
covet
he lied about he was you're he is not
going to be a reliable source of
information and he's not going to be a
reliable partner to work with he's not
well he's either because he's a [ __ ]
Republican he's either going to lie or
he's not going to acknowledge it I mean
we've already seen the early
developments of his strategy which is
I'm going to go to the opposite side of
the state that had little damage and
show how much good is happening right
now because of our strategy and our plan
but really he's just ignoring the west
side of the state that was completely
ravaged by this hurricane and so by not
acknowledging it right by focusing all
the effort by flipping pancakes at a
Waffle House or you know heading water
out and in in Saint Augustine or areas
that aren't actually uh
devastated right he's wearing his
[ __ ] white water boot like whatever I
don't know what the [ __ ] he's wearing
but it's all performative it's all
performative nothing he's doing is
actually helping the people of Florida
and the people he's given his attention
to in drawing a distraction from he's
not actually helping right he's going
around like oh look some branches went
down like yeah to the same extent that
when it's windy here in La palm trees
fall apart right
but in Florida he's completely ignoring
the part of the state that was actually
hurt that was actually having people
that suffered lost their homes their
livelihood their family members he's
ignoring those people and by not
acknowledging it he's very much taken
the Trump approach which is like I'm not
responsible
you know if I don't like out of sight
out of mind and that is what Republicans
do if I don't see it and we don't talk
about it it was never really there right
and that is what a strategy is whether
to lie or just flat out ignore
and just like trying to shut down the
government in the middle of a natural
disaster they're going to say your fault
right it's your fault right you're it's
your fault
Brandon did this Brandon did this I
didn't do it I tried like Gabe said I
sent a memo I sent a memo you know well
and that's and that's and that's the
story of the Republican party here is
that they don't want to govern because
they know governing's hard and it's hard
to re when you actually govern for the
people it's really hard to screw the
people it's really hard if you if you
really focus on governing for the people
who elected you and for your
constituents it's really hard to [ __ ]
them in the end it's really hard to so
what you do is you just point the finger
with projection at the other side while
you're taking the money taking the power
taking all the fruit for yourself that
way your constituents get [ __ ] and you
blame it on the other side because
they're the ones they're the ones I mean
if this hurricane had not hit Florida my
guess is every single Republican
Congressman the the governor of Florida
the Senators Republican senators from
Florida would say abolish FEMA abolish
fee FEMA they would be wanting to
abolish FEMA but now they love FEMA they
love FEMA today because they're going to
steal they're going to steal from it not
only are they going to steal not only
going to steal the effort and the
recovery that FEMA actually is
organizing but they're going to steal
they're gonna try to steal the [ __ ]
money it is going to happen folks that's
what they do that is what they do
and Tony I tell you you got me right
here in the fields and that one in in
that opening because you're absolutely
right you're absolutely right it can't
just be me and you and Gabe screaming
and hey this is going on this and the
other people have to pull their heads
out of the Kardashians asses for a
minute stop watching all the pop pop
culture [ __ ] and focus on what's
[ __ ] going on because I'm telling you
folks this is your last chance
if you [ __ ] this up and you give
Republicans power I if you let the
Republicans even take the house
we are [ __ ]
we as a country are [ __ ] like you've
never seen
these people are insane
they are insane [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ] we'll watch you die
kind of people
they they
I can't stress it hard enough
it can't just be us you know it cannot
just be us I got I I got four voters
yesterday guys I got four voters one of
them I took my wife to Red Lobster and
we went to lunch at Red Lobster and my
waitress was there and I'm like are you
registered to vote she's like yes my mom
made me promise to go register for to
vote and I did and I said okay well look
look let me tell you something let me
tell you why
not just you have to vote you have to
get one of your friends to vote because
you see that guy at that table right
there and I pointed over there and of
course I'm sitting at a dinner table
I've got my hat off it's sitting in a
chair you know you've got this guy who
walked in with a American Flag t-shirt
that turned into AR-15s draping down you
know what I mean really this is the guy
it sounds like you will not stop my
writing he had a beard like my old beard
before I shaved it off you know and I
told her and she happened to be
African-American she was a wonderful
person Alexis if you see this you were a
wonderful human being
I said that racist [ __ ] right
there
is going to vote
your vote is going to cancel out his
vote that's right but for us to win you
have to bring one more person with you
that's right right because that's how we
get ahead that's right if you vote just
you all you're doing is canceling that
racist [ __ ] vote out
you have to bring somebody with you and
she was like wow I I never thought about
it that way you know like but that's the
truth it can't just be me voting can't
be just the people in the chat people in
our bubble we have to get busy get out
there get people you go through a
drive-through recruit somebody
mm-hmm you go to dinner recruit somebody
you go to Walmart recruit somebody
everywhere you go you got to be talking
about this for the next month man
October 11th is a deadline here in Texas
people you have to be registered by
October 11th after October 11th I can
get no more voters if they're not
already registered got a few more days
folks get out there and check your
registration check other people's
registration as well make sure they are
registered to vote get your buddy system
going that's right that's right Texas
Paul I always enjoy having you here on
Tuesdays I know the audience does too
and I I hate to go because
um I I love talking about all this stuff
and but we really got to get to the
shitless Roundup I got I got some
Herschel wall I know you don't want to
talk about Erza Walker but I got I gotta
run down through this and why this is so
important why this is so important to
the election because I think that's
that's what people need to understand
and I said it in the beginning that this
Herschel Walker story yeah it's about
him and his son really the person that's
terrified the most morning that's
[ __ ] their diapers in Georgia is
Kemp is Governor Kemp this is bad for
him this is really bad for him and his
campaign and I'll explain that but Texas
Paul tell us where we can find you jelly
as to where the audience can find you I
know you have some stuff going over on
YouTube now tell them what they can do
over there on YouTube for you this
Wednesday 99 p.m Central we have TNT me
and Tennessee Brando get together and
break down what's going on and on
Sundays at uh nine a our pardon me I
moved it to 10 because a lot of the West
coasters were like please don't make me
get up this early please don't do that
so I said okay 10 o'clock uh in the
morning central time we're doing uh
coffee with Texas Paul we just have a
nice conversation about what's going on
when of course take questions from the
chat or at the end of every show so
that's great enjoy it folks come see me
yeah go go follow go follow And
subscribe it's free it's subscribe on
YouTube to Texas balls Channel and he's
got a free show over there for you two
of them every single week it's easy to
find and I got a link tree up it's link
uh there's a link tr.e slash Texas Paul
that's great that's great
um the Texas Paul thanks for joining us
everyone stick around we'll be right
back with the [ __ ] list Roundup right
after this break my friend you have a
good one we'll see you next Tuesday best
podcast jump bad cop best podcast there
is guys the best podcast
at old time and he fumbles there at the
end thanks a lot Texas boy I appreciate
it we'll talk to you soon my friend
everyone go follow Texas Paul's Channel
on YouTube we'll talk everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this break